e aí galera que a gente vai falar tudo
com vocês a única que eu tô agora eu
estou na minha cama em cima dos meus
presentes dos fãs de brasília eu você e
uso do marco e você pelo tel
pois é eu adorei brasília superou todas
as minhas expectativas para o show de
brasília foi uma coisa louca só mostra
como é que foi o brasil defende rafael
menino gay
o cara foi muito lindo amei demais esse
show aí deu tanta gente que depois de
ter cabe outra sessão sob as pessoas que
esperaram para poder ir pra outro sessão
o legal dessa outra sessão é porque como
sobrou mais tempo para identificar o
ponto de bater um papo com essa galera
depois acabou fiquei conversando com a
galera
[Aplausos]
a gente olha vocês não estão entendendo
é o seguinte a gente fez na seleção há
pouco em tudo ainda ficou esse mundo de
gente vai entrar e quente tem gente abre
outra sessão estamos que bateu um papo
com a galera olha aí top apresentar aqui
bom né camisinha que foi profunda
[Música]
eu adorei demais fazer muito obrigado
brasília e vai ter aqui em teresina dia
2 agora sete horas da noite no theatro 4
de setembro ea pensão porque vende
ligeiro viu a partir de agora no momento
que você está assistindo esse vídeo tem
ingressos à venda na bilheteria do
theatro 4 de setembro primeira vez que
eu vou me apresentar no 4 de setembro em
teresina não é só eu enviei civil 10
horas da manhã a partir das 10 horas da
manhã estava vendendo ingresso na
bilheteria do theatro 4 de setembro a
depois chega na hora e aí a já estava
esgotado e eu avisei vem dirigir então
vai agora não pode de setembro teresina
é a vez de vocês quero fazer bonito
também é que gente estou muito feliz
porque eu estou muito feliz
é o seguinte no vídeo eu fiz o batmóvel
leia aqui no brasil apresenta pra vocês
meu gato é wesley safadão e ray [ __ ]
não saía do in motion r 10 mil e atingir
eu criei esse gato e rato de estimação
todo mundo que me assiste desde o começo
que me acompanha há algum tempo sabe que
eu amo animal que eu tenho já uma
cachorrinha adotei que a minerva década
minerva academy né brinca de minério
gente a minerva está lá na minha casa
minha casa de pai mãe e meio lá na minha
cidade porque a minerva foi
diagnosticada com calazar e calazar o
seguinte ou criada num monte de remédio
o manda matar eu logicamente rokia neto
nem phone eo meu monstro do veterinário
então ele sabe cuidar melhor do que eu
tava lá acontece um dia estava no cinema
é eu saio no que eu saí eu passei na
lojinha do lado do lado do do lugar que
sempre ficam as galinhas enxergue animal
para o tartá é sair desse esse jeito é
feito lá eu fui ver o gat gimhae que
brinca que brincando que brincando né a
vamos embora na hora que eu viria a
chegar aqui eu esse gato é 28 vai levar
para a casa da sua estadia o bichinho
foi nada como é que eu faço quando está
em cingapura está muito amor carinho
pensando na minha face tem o apoio total
nesse meu coração é amor e de gatos aqui
pra casa caiu de e eu dei a ele é
incrível nome de wesley safadão porque
ele é um gato muito safado
a aae o que acontece e começou a
conviver como começou a crescer e ele
fica sempre a minha casa pra casa do
vizinho que a obra não é sempre entrando
na casa dele pra mim pela janela faz
tudo de bom só que aí gente eu viajei
ele sempre desse jeito da minha casa com
a cara do brasil na minha casa do
parente esse gato não sumiu sumiu sumiu
sumiu em agonia de gente quando você se
acostuma com o animal onde se apoia em
sua casa já está na porta pra você se a
gente quando você entra em casa você
olha não tem nada mais o meu que chama
eles afagaram diga-se repertório não é e
já vem não quero que ele saia do meu
quarto eu digo vai [ __ ]
sai de repente ouvi na minha casa e esse
gato não está mais aqui dentro eu fico
tipo assim
[Música]
eu fiquei sem chão eu sabia o que fazer
aí eu fui pra outra cidade fazer mais
nada porque foste brasil ele foi uma
lenda do mundo quando recebeu a notícia
que o gato apareceu na cara do brasil e
meu deu é só vem cá hoje até mais
digitais que ó tema e se [ __ ] entendam a
grandes dão o tamanho dele quer fazer
massagem o liga mas a gente vai comendo
em 23 mas a gente dê no time
[Música]
galera eu aqui deitada em cima do
presente quando nada escuto isso
[Aplausos]
então é isso estou muito feliz que meu
gato voltou eu queria contar pra você e
depois eu vou contar depois de fazer um
vídeo dizendo como é que é ter um gato
pra você então não sei se você quer de
teresina dia 2 agora quinta feira tem
stand up lá no theatro 4 de setembro às
sete horas da noite a vendendo ingressos
lá no teatro agora nesse momento até
agora então você vai lá agora comprou
seu ingresso r$15 a6 eo meu gato porto
lindo maravilhoso e eu fiz show em
brasília e foi lindo e é isso aí e se
você gostou clique não gostei porque se
você não gostar eu vou pegar todos esses
usos foi cantor adicional
esse aqui é o meu instagram